欢迎收看理财大人秀的
筹码教学单元
歌有筹必报
今天呢是第二季的二十二集
二二二
好大家想说
你之前都没有在报集数
你今天干嘛报啊
报呢是要跟大家讲
其实我们这个单元做很久了
那小哥最近呢
很有一顆放假的心
其實一直都有啦
看我穿著衣服就知道
他穿著海洋的藍
我也穿著海洋的藍
我們的心已經飛走了
所以小哥接下來會放一個長假
啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦
大家聽得出來嗎
他是拓哉我是智子
所以我們要很珍惜
今天這一集的教學
因為這一集小哥教學完
會修一個比較長的假期
那这一期要交什么呢
大家看到的时候
应该是在中秋节廉价的时候
我们来交
因为盘面上最近
其实大户的筹码是比较涣散的
离开台股比较多
所以我们看到好多的主流股
主题股
他们都从高档级修正非常多了之外
还有有的人是遇到所谓的倒霉事
遇到不好的状况
跌停板 跌停板 跌停板
但是跌停板总有打开的时候嘛
所以今天小哥要来教大家
当你手上的股票
遇到这种倒霉的状况
跌停板 跌停板 跌停板
它哪一天会有讯号反弹
也许不见得是倒霉事
你也不知道发生什么事
总之一直跌
它会有打开反弹的那一天
什么讯号 怎么抢
手脚要多快
今天小哥会全教学
为什么今天想要教这个
好好的中秋夜
因为周末发生了一个事情
我看全国大概都蛮难过的
就是民洋火災嘛
是
而且在屏東我的家鄉
對啊
剛好最近有很多股票也跌很多
是
那大家都在想說
那跌很多到底該怎麼辦
所以我們就要再教一下
那跌很多該怎麼辦
第一當然是手上有的人
跌很多怎麼辦
第二就是大家各自平良心的
因為像民洋那種我就不敢碰
可是真的也有人問我說
啊他怎麼會打開吧
如果他後續還能營運的話
會不會可以搶反彈
大概一天是沒什麼問題啦
搶一天勝率還滿高的
但是重點是你要知道是哪一天啊
例如說像昨天就有人繼續搶了啊
不行啦
不曉得他在想什麼
我覺得第一天
你跟我看的一樣耶
就是例如說
跌停版第一天
我都會想到底為什麼有人會接啊
這事情很大耶
他沒在看電視鏡
對啊 這事情很大耶
對啊 難道他打電話去下單的時候
他永遠都不會跟他講說
欸 這隻跌停 手痕死 偽賣很多張
因為要嘛電話下單 要嘛手機下單
手機下單一看偽賣那麼多
你買一張你是想把它敲開嗎
我覺得就直接破萬張的賣單
對啊 你買一張你又敲不開
那你到底是在買那一張要幹嘛
不知道在想什麼
所以呢 我們就要教各位
如何不要買到那種跌停 手痕死的
你又去買
那個就比較危險了
所以來看一下
反彈常見的迷失
第一個 跌多一定漲嗎
那跌多到底跌到哪裡才叫多啊
對嘛 跌多必漲我覺得對
可是跌到哪裡叫多
對啊
跌10% 跌20%還是跌50%
你看去年空投年的時候
有多少人是膝蓋漲跟腳踝漲
對啊
以前有一張股票 我手上有
什麼東西
14根跌停你知道嗎
康有啊
喔康有KY喔
你有你一定是空單
你才能笑得出來
因為康有KY那個很特別
那個在我發現的前兩天
就發現第一個董事長賣股票
然後有分點連續賣9張
那我們算一算董事長幾乎快把他股票給出清了
那時候隔天呢
這個隔天看來沒有跌停喔
那隔天去賣他幾張之後
他就連續跌停14根
哇賽
可是這中間你就有爆滿14根嗎
有 從頭爆到尾
因為我們就看量
只要量沒出來就一直爆
量沒出來就一直爆
差點被你拐了
差點回答郭婉榮證交稅事件我不知道那是什麼 我不知道我也不知道 還出息不管我是誰好 那這個這是第一個 所以跌多幣長
到底跌哪根 所以跌到哪個比較多
康有 你看看 跌6根夠多了吧
跌到第14根
對 所以這個
迷失我們待會會幫各位破解
那第二個呢 量縮跌不下去
無量跌停 這不是更恐怖嗎
無上跌停
很多人說亮縮 亮縮跌不下去
不是這樣子啦
大盤有人這樣看
你的母體越大的話
有可能啦
不過通常我們會覺得跌不下去
都是要出大量
是
有人接嘛
有人接才容易跌不下去
那第三呢
爆量下跌要趕快跑嗎
高檔是這樣沒錯吧
高檔是這樣 低檔就不是了
低檔爆量下跌
那就代表已經要反彈了
所以這個是有差別的
好 那我們來看一下
這個上次
這個阿格力
聊完之後就燒掉
可能啊
還有別檔也是
很恐怖
他聊完就燒掉
真的
那我們來看這個旭富
那虚幅呢 各位看一下
他在跌第一根的时候
假设你去抢
那后面呢 又跌了四根
哇 很伤耶
所以你不要以为量缩
就会止跌
无量跌停更恐怖
对 量缩是不会止跌的
无量跌停那是很恐怖的
所以你就要每天去判断一下
他的量到底会不会爆
是
那通常我们都是看低盘的量
像我今天我就去抢明安
因为他今天低盘就有量了
只要低盘有量
他就很有可能就像这一根红K一样
他出现一根大红K
那出现一根大红K之后呢
那就要看这家公司的状况了
有些股票你还记得亚新吗
好恶熟喔
什么都做的亚新你知道吗
以前我在交出的時候
我同事還跟我講
小哥啊 你要不要買這支雅興
什麼都做 連火箭都會
這真的假的
你看外資買很多 這真的假的
後來發現全部都假的
後來從24塊點到8塊
連續點贏到8塊
唯一打開的那一天
就是逃命的最後一天
後面就下市了
所以打開那一天你沒賣
下次
所以這很恐怖的案例
所以我們都講
你假如手上沒有的
你就玩那一天就好
當衝就解決了
那假如說
跌廳打開
再鎖回去
再還沒有鎖回去那時候
你要趕快賣掉
像之前的試薪我就玩過一次
9點2分
因為試抽被人家亂戳
9點2分去搶
打開了
拉了15塊
有3%多
立馬又再鎖回去
4分鐘時間
中間還經過2分鐘的緩戳
所以他實際上只有2分鐘
只有2分鐘可以跟你玩
2分鐘可以跟你玩
後面就鎖回去
只玩2分鐘真的不行
那邊2分鐘就大賺了
所以你一定要判斷好
到底有沒有出量
所以你要玩這種
出量就是个重点
没出量就不要玩
没出量不要玩
没出量是很危险的
好 来看一下
这个之前的股票
像5904的保雅
你看 爆量下跌
这个位置你觉得怎么样
该卖 还是该买
如果它跌那么多了又爆量
就代表有内行人出手了
造华馆 厉害
因为今天
明安有一萬多張的量
小哥出手了一萬張吧
沒有 沒有 沒有 沒有 沒有那麼多
好 那這個
這個喔
這個我曾經去問過一個
股市文人
哎呦 我認識嗎
你認識
我認識是不是
最近要出書的一個股市文人
是玄學那位嗎
是的 玄學那位
對
我還特別把這種圖給大家看
我說請看一下
這種線型
你會站在買方還是賣方對他一看就說這一定是要站在賣方的他就是好像是漲時說多跌時說空的那一型對不對所以就變得很厲害啊
很厲害的反
對真的是
跌時說這一定要賣的啊
都跌到有量了 代表會繼續跌啊
我說你的直覺果然是蠻正確的
你的直覺這個
你只要 你這輩子只要按照你的直覺
反著做
反著做 你的別墅就靠大海
我們來看一下 贊的股票就這樣
你看它跌到粗量了
跌到粗量你不要以為它要繼續跌
它沒有 各位來看一下隔天就怎麼樣
隔天開低就往上面走了
開低走高了
那為什麼開低走高呢
因为你想一下
我们来看一下保养后面的走势
他在这边出量
那出量代表说
想卖的人都卖掉了
因为没有迭廷说实
想卖都卖掉了
想买的人都买到了
想买的人要抢碗坛的
都买到了
那卖的人卖掉了
所以第一个没有卖压
卖压消除
第二个买的人进场
它的成本不一样
它成本是在低点
成本在低点的人
他的信心会比较坚定一点
比较不会害怕
所以这种很容易就反弹
反弹可能也只有两天而已
你不要以为反弹会
天长地久
回到原点
这种抢反弹
我们抢两天
抢两天已经抢很久了
像小哥刚刚就两分钟
对
这两天对我而言已经很久了
足足完了两天
两天大红K该跑了
这个已经反弹到月线了
够了
所以你在低档有强反弹的
其实这两根红K也很补
对
那尤其是你想要用全正进场的
那个也是赚蛮多的
两天很补
再下去就虚了
对
没错
所以在高档不要一直玩
一直玩不大好
所以什么股票可以强反弹
好 什么情况
第一个呢 出现在地板股
那地板股呢
你就要用小哥统计过的地板股
小哥的筹码KELA
里面帮大家统计的地板股
其实我这边常常跟大家宣导
因为筹码这种资讯是要靠
想办法程式去把它捞起来的
所以有一些工具是必要的
好 那第二个呢
确认跌破地板的时候
你可以看一下成交量
那通常我们在地板股里面
我们就会看它的量
只要在地板股它都是有量
那量越大
他越來越準
昨天明安
雖然無量跌停
看起來是無量跌停
但是到尾盤的時候
他就出量了
昨天明安的量
是他20巨量的兩倍多
尾盤就有人知道
對
所以今天的開盤跌停
我就去買了
結果一買就打開
收平盤
對
等於是一個漲停板的意思
10%
而且我是佛系當沖
開盤買 收盤賣
佛系當沖
好 第二個呢
確認跌破地板的時候
要成交兩倍
第三呢 避開小型股
均量不要太多
越小越不好
越容易被人為操控
而且手碼也少
對 那這名單比較特別
因為有點事件型
對
那我還是玩了
嘴巴說不要 身體很誠實
這是怕各位受傷
因為有時候學員都問我說
喬哥 你明明說不要做
為什麼你自己來做
對 我們自己玩咧
為了你的安全啊
這句話好像怪怪的
這東西有毒 你不要吃 我先吃
沒有 就是這個比較危險
我們現在教很多比較安全的方法
這個比較危險
當然賠錢的機率會稍微提高一點
那我們自己賠就好
不希望你受傷
學員就在旁邊看你玩
好
我们利用极端覆乏离率来抢板坛
那什么时候呢
这个覆乏离率会超大
很恐慌的时候
像这个刚发生火灾的名阳公司
最近它的覆乏离率会越来越大
好
那这个覆乏离率越大呢
是抓转折的好时机
但是你要记得
一定要有量的配合
没有量不行
那第二个呢连续黑黑暴量隔天殺低強所以這邊最重要的就是要爆量第三呢 變成紅K我們就要跑了
那萬一他也是一直黑K
大概就是你第二次進場
五天之後
腳都沒有彈 你還是要跑了
不過這個機率是蠻小的
所以在這邊教各位
怎麼樣來搶反彈
好 SOP來了
SOP来了
第一个呢
我们咋把资金份十等份
可用资金哦
然后呢
当天晚上出现在地板下的个股
各位你可以每天
每天的去研究我的笔记本
是
我都会写
所以在地板下的个股
那地板下个股一定成交量
是20次俊阳的两倍
那假如成交量是20次俊阳的五倍
十倍
倍数越多
反弹机会越高
这个我们有统计过的
列入自选
第一份资金10%
在第二天杀地爆量
你就要去抢了
像今天民安是直接
这个低盘就爆量
所以第一盘我就抢了
第三天开高上涨武力
就获利了结
真的不要弄太久
第三天杀地爆量
第二份资金再抢一次
还可以再抢一次
对
那这第二份资金是20%
通常杀月低
比我们的金额越大
有点这个盗金字塔的这种做法
是
说错了 是金字塔做法
金字塔往下买越多
金字塔 挣金字塔
挣金字塔 对对对
下面要最多 对对 下面最多
好 那最后就要抢反弹就要抢一堂
有赚就要跑 没赚还是要跑
还是要跑 对
不能跟他天长地久
来看一下过往的案例
例如說像這個建設啊
建設我們看 殺到這邊連續性的出量
而且建設這個還挺麻煩的
你問不太出什麼原因
突然殺下有量 沒有什麼新聞跟消息
不過只要有量 有量後面就容易談
有量後面就容易談
那我們來看一下 建設後面就怎麼樣
後面就殺低走高啦
所以這種殺低走高 建設還不錯
它也走了一大段
是 有很大一段
畢竟它也是提彩股
它在這裡殺低出量
出量後面就彈
這個呢
我們常常見
所以只要殺低出量的
你都可以好好做觀察
都是強反彈的好時機
好 殺低有量
建設又加上有伺服器提彩
一直都過去蠻強的
所以很適用在每一種狀況
因為它這一段跌的時候
可以有到處打聽啊
他怎樣啦
沒有人知道他怎樣的
不過只要有量代表說
有人又進來了
對
終於面平
因為之前股價蠻貴的
有人進來你就不用害怕
是
好
接下來我們看這個
這張股票
大家會覺得比較
不是溫溫吞吞的嗎
溫溫吞吞的也可以進地板
也可以
溫溫吞吞的
它的地板線會比較窄一點
像台季雲 殺到這邊也出量了
一出量之後 各位來看一下
隔天也是一樣
隔天開低 後面也是漲上來
漲上來之後來看看台季雲後面的走勢
後面的走勢就漲怎樣 你看 至少15天
對 殺低 出量之後 後面就反彈
所以這種交易的方法交給各位
這種交易方法其實勝率蠻高的
好 所以剛剛小哥有特別提醒
其實搶板談我們應該不只交一次了
但是因為他真的適合
我覺得要比較手腳快
高段一點的投資人
因為搶得到你要跑
搶不到更要跑
跟搶銀行一樣
那還是歡迎大家訂閱我們的榮耀班
因為榮耀班裡面小哥會告訴大家
他最近在觀察哪一些標的
已經殺到地板股了
隨時你就是等什麼
等他出量
代表有知道內情的人進去接
除了名陽
到底有沒有機會打開讓你賺到那一波
當然這還強調看你的良心
像趙華是覺得這種公安意外
我可能就不碰
但有很多公司是
你真的不知道他在跌什麼呢
現在跌到地板股了
大戶什麼時候會進場
都在榮耀班會交給你喔